you know it's funny I didn't think
species sequels got theatrical releases
that's weird
[Music]
splice okay so this just in brilliant
scientific geneticists are no longer old
dudes who look like Colonel Sanders
they're attractive thirty year olds that
one of them can act
okay so splice is the story of these two
scientists who do this really hush-hush
experiment of creating a life by
splicing together the DNA of a few
different species human included and a
little she mutant named Ren ages really
fast like brundlefly skit or some [ __ ]
and goes from looking like a Mouser from
Ninja Turtles to looking like a model
with kangaroo feet in about a month's
time give or take so in our recent days
of scientific breakthroughs you know the
whole artificially creating biological
life thing I was looking forward to
splice but Chuck went up to wasted
potential
at a point in the movie I realized that
splice is what happens when a scientific
movie is written by a high-school
student like take an interesting premise
and surround it with two main characters
who flip flopped their nature like one
minute this person loves dread and the
other one hates her and the next minute
this person loves draining the other one
who used to love dread now hates her and
rinse and repeat that unbelievable
flip-flop [ __ ]
throughout and top it off with scenes
that are supposed to be shocking but you
end up laughing you're not supposed to
laugh but you laugh because it's just
ludicrous and you just know the director
was all like I'm gonna make a movie that
makes people question where animalistic
nature ends and human nature begins I'm
gonna blur the line snow dude you
blurred the lines between comedy and
horror that's what you did which I guess
is talent now Adrian Brody he's a solid
actor I got nothing bad to say about the
guy I mean he was he was good in the
movie he's won an Oscar for God's sakes
the chick from Dawn of the Dead not so
much I mean some scenes were kind of
embarrassing to watch but she was
talking sometimes you just wanted to be
like it's okay your mom still loves you
it's okay your mom still loves you and I
put a lot of the blame on the writer I
mean sometimes she was talking or Adrien
Brody and you're just like why would
they say that people don't really talk
like that they would not do that in that
situation like there's a scene where bad
actress ladies like really pissed off at
Adrien Brody I mean she was pissed I
mean we're talking she wasn't messing
around this was this was pissed and then
five minutes later she's fine and
they're working together again and this
wasn't like I'll be fine in five minutes
pissed [ __ ] was real but no and it's
that kind of unrealistic [ __ ] that makes
the movie forgettable as hell I
ultimately left this movie with the same
feeling I had after I watched the movie
Holloman
Holloman when you were gonna watch
Holloman you're like yeah it's a movie
about an invisible guy who loses his
mind that's awesome but it turned out to
be I know what you did in the lab last
summer it's kind of the same thing
this movie was species meets insert
whatever movie has really horribly
uneven character shuffling in the middle
right here meets 10 minutes of jeepers
creepers best I can compare it you want
a really cool scientific movie with
taboo experiments that turn to [ __ ]
watch Jurassic Park
alright otally different vibe but try to
tell me I'm wrong I mean seriously
Adrien Brody you want an Oscar you had
nothing better to do
seriously it's that hard for you to find
work and then ever but if you guys like
what you seen here then click here to
see more and do the SUBSCRIBE thing
because there's more coming
[Music]